hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the cynic is a short dialogue between
lucian and a cynic that has
for a long time and by many people been
attributed
to the author lucian there's others who
would say that it's not actually biam
it's by somebody
that they just label as pseudo lucian
which means we don't know who it is but
it's not him
and the main argument for why that would
be the case
is that the cynic actually comes out
pretty good
in the dialogue and is able to respond
to everything that lucian is saying
whereas in some of his other dialogues
he he makes fun
of at least some cynics and says that
they're kind of
you know hypocrites and they're not
really behaving according to their
ideology
but it's very interesting in this
dialogue we're getting a very
lucid presentation of the
way of living and way of thinking of the
cynics now whether it's by
lucian or not by lucian we can put that
aside and say that this is
of interest in part because it turns
on the central issue for the cynics
of what does a human being really need
what do they have want of you could say
and what constitutes sufficiency for
them
and indeed self-sufficiency or
out archaea the the ability to live
on one's own and the dialogue
begins by lucian calling the cynic
to give an account of himself and you
know lucian doesn't pull any punches as
a character
in this or if he is the author as the
author he says
you need to tell us why you behave the
way that you do i mean look at you you
don't have anything
you're begging from people you stink
your hair is all unkempt you've got that
rough cloak
you know bushy beard you're really a
mess man
you're you're like a homeless guy and
indeed cynics very
often were so he says
your feet are bare you chose a wandering
outcast
beastly and that's an important term
beastly animalistic
life so you know why are you doing it
what's the point of
all of this he says your old cloak has a
plentiful load of
filth to carry about with it and the
response given by the cynic is
is very simple and he's going to explain
this along the way
it meets my needs it was easy to come by
and it gives its owner no trouble it is
the cloak for me
and then he says don't you call
extravagance of vice
an economy of virtue and he says if you
find me living economically and others
extravagantly
why are you blaming me why are you
complaining
about me why are you criticizing me
instead of criticizing
them so already here we've got an
argument in favor
of the cynic lifestyle and then the
cynic kind of
turns the the tables on lucian
and us the readers and he says let's be
philosophical about this what is
want what is it to be in need
to be destitute what is
sufficiency and he says the cynics
actually uh enjoy
sufficiency and he's saying this in
response to
the the other guy saying your lifestyle
isn't just wanting it's destitution
you're as broke as you can get
you've got garments and they're dirty
and stinky and
probably lice infested you are the
epitome of lacking things and so he says
okay a man's sufficiency is that which
meets his necessities
and want occurs when the supply falls
short of necessity does not meet the
need so then the question here is well
what does the cynic actually need and
this is based on the question of
what does a human being need and the
cynics thought that
we human beings quite often get very
confused about this and think that we
need things
that we don't and he's got a really
interesting line of reasoning here
talking about protection when we ask
people
what do you actually need what are your
bare necessities they'll say well you
know i need clothing
i need you know roof over my head i
don't have to actually own it
i could just be renting it or hanging
out in it but i need
that sort of thing and we can say well
what do you need those for
for protection and the cynic says
what do you need protection for what is
the purpose
of protection and this is kind of a
place where
you know a lot of us would stop short
but it's it's kind of a no-brainer
what do we need protection for to
preserve things from
being damaged he says it's the better
condition
of the protected you know think about
when you park your car
in a garage or a carport you know that's
to keep like crap from falling on top of
it like
tree limbs or hail or rain so
here's where the cynic gets very you
know
we could say uh
very focused on classic examples he says
look at my feet buddy
are my feet in worse condition than
yours i'm walking around barefoot you
have nice shoes
what's the purpose of feet is it to
smell nice is it to
you know stick and wiggle your toes
around or something like that
no it's to walk around that's the whole
point of feet
am i any less able to walk around
with my lifestyle than you are with
yours as a matter of fact i think i
might be in better shape
than you are for walking around
he says what about the rest of my body
if it's in worse condition it must be
weaker strength being the virtue of the
body is my body weaker
and you know he's talking to somebody
the cynic is somebody who
ranges all around who does physical
exercises who is
has made his body tough and lucian has
to say
no your body seems to be just fine and
he says what about my
my eating habits you know if i'm eating
bad food that should damage my body
right but i seem to be healthy to you
don't i
even though i'm eating simple food even
though i'm eating
whatever i can get and whatever you know
i can
procure and make cheaply so he says
this proves that my way of living is
indeed satisfying my
needs i'm in good condition you on the
other hand
i'm not quite sure about so this is
interesting
this then opens up the door to another
challenge
notice how lucian frames this
he says well okay that that's quite true
and
you are in good shape but you're not
really making
good use out of life i mean there's this
wonderful frame
he says nature and the gods have given
us the earth and brought all sorts of
good things out of us
providing us with abundance not merely
for our necessities but for our
pleasures
but you cynics you abstain from all or
nearly all of it
and you utilize these good things no
more than the beasts you drink water you
don't drink wine
like the rest of us you eat what you
pick up like a dog
and the dog's bed is as good as yours
straw is good enough for both of you
your clothes are no more presentable
than a beggar
so what's wrong with you i mean look at
all the
wonderful things that we have that we
can enjoy
you say that you're honoring god but
really
you are acting like somebody who thinks
they're better
than god uh you're passing up
all these great things god must have
been wrong in making sheep wooly
right we can make nice wool clothes out
of the things that we get from the sheep
filling grapes with wine or juice at
least
providing our infinite variety of oil
honey and all the rest that we
might have food of every sort pleasant
drink money soft beds fine houses and
all the wonderful paraphernalia of
civilization the productions of art are
god's gifts to us too
why would you want to live without that
stuff
you you could enjoy a great life and the
cynic says
okay i'm going to give you a analogy
here
so imagine as he says
a rich man indulging genial kindly
instincts
entertains at a banquet all sorts and
conditions of men so there's
everybody invited to the party some of
them are sick
others are healthy and the dishes
provided are as various as the guests so
this sounds like a great dinner party
doesn't it
he says there is one of these to whom
nothing comes amidst he has his finger
in every dish
not only the ones with an easy reach but
also some
that are way off that were intended for
invalids this though he's in good
health has not more than one stomach
requires little to nourish him and is
likely to be upset by
a surplus what's your opinion of this
this person
is this an intelligent person so what
we've got here is somebody who's at the
banquet
he's eating everybody's dishes kind of
willy-nilly
and some of them are made for invalids
and some of them are for healthy people
he's actually probably going to make
himself unhealthy
in the process isn't he and he's taking
from other people who should
have that sort of meal and you know
lucian says no this is stupid
he says is he temperate no not that and
then he says okay now imagine another
guest
he's unconscious of all that variety he
finds some dish that's close by
that suits his need eats moderately love
of it confines himself to it without a
glance at all the rest
isn't he a more temperature a more
self-controlled
person and a better man than all the
others
lucian says yeah and then the cynic says
duh
that's me i am the the temperate man
you're the one who needs a bit of
everybody else's stuff
i don't need that there's no reason why
i have to take wine if i don't if i
don't have to have it
i'm cool with laying down like a dog
and sleeping if i get good sleep that's
the
measure here not that i have to try to
take everything i can
and then he actually says you make bad
use of things
you are like the greedy unrestrained
person
who lays hands on everything you can't
be content
with the stuff that's nearby you have to
like get stuff from overseas
you know you're not content with the
local
grains or legumes or wine you have to
order it from
egypt and all sorts of other places
and so he says you prefer the exotic to
the homegrown the costly to the cheap
the rare to the common
you would rather have troubles and
complications
than avoid them and and you're getting
them because
all the things that you're looking for
the gold the silver the costly houses
the elaborate dresses
all that is bringing trouble and toil
and danger blood and mortality and ruin
other people have to suffer when you get
these things you fight with people about
them
that's no life for a reasonable person
that's actually kind of a sucky life
and he says it's purposeless it's
pointless
why because the things that you have the
luxuries
the money the special food the sexual
indulgence
they're not actually getting you
anything particularly good he says
embroidered clothes have no more warmth
in them than others
in our day what would we call it
designer clothing
for the purpose of wearing clothing
you know the the cheap generic brand is
probably as good
as the designer item it just doesn't
have the monogram on it you know which
is often embroidered
he says gilded houses keep out the rain
no better
the drink is a wonderful phrase is no
sweeter
out of a silver cup or a gold one for
that
matter right and as to the elaborate
dressing of food
i need hardly say that instead of aiding
nutrition it
injures the body and breeds disease in
it and we can think about
you know the use of sugar throughout the
ages
and how much sugar is in some of the
products that we don't even realize it's
in
or high fructose corn syrup or excessive
salt
or and we can go down the list right all
these things that are in our food that
we don't need
if we actually eat simple healthy food
it talks about the abuse of the sexual
instinct
the cynic said it's pretty easy to
satisfy it you can do it by yourself
right or you can find
anybody you don't have to let it
dominate you he says so easily managed
if indulgence were not made
an object and here he talks about
perverting the uses of things misusing
things
according to unnatural purposes and he
makes fun of this guy for getting
carried around
on a litter we could make fun of people
in our own time
for needing you know an suv
or taking some fancy transportation
instead of catching the bus
or the train or you know using yours we
used to call them
leather personnel carriers meaning your
boots you know cynics of course are
walking
barefoot but in our environment we
probably need boots
right you can do all that sort of stuff
and he also talks about another really
interesting example
he says when people use edible things
not for food but to get dye out of the
murrex dyers
the people who would get purple out of
this shellfish
are they not abusing god's gifts lucian
says no no you can use it for that
purpose
and the cynic says it wasn't made for
that
the shellfish was not made to
have its essence extracted from it
killing it in the process
so that you can dye things purple
and look cool you know because of that
and so there's a number of examples that
he gives about that
the cynic also goes on the counter
attack
saying you know if your complaint was on
target
you would be the one who's actually
going after the gods
because the gods don't need a single
thing that's part of why they're
gods as a matter of fact it's not just
gods
it also includes heroes and demigods he
uses
hercules or heracles who is a prime
example for the cynics
he says take heracles the best man who
ever lived
rightly reckoned to god was it
wrong-headedness that made him go around
and nothing but a lion's skin
insensible to all the needs you feel no
he was not wrong-headed who righted
other people's wrongs he was not poor
who was lord of land and sea wherever he
met he was master
he never met as superior or equal as
long as he lived
if he wanted to have sheets and shoes
and you know
million women and you know purple dye
and he could have had any of that sort
of stuff but he didn't instead he did
the things that he thought were
important and he used the bare
necessities for his body
theseus he talks about son of poseidon
and
others as well you know like that time
he says
i want to be like those guys i want to
be self-sufficient
i want to grow a beard now you know
female cynics
would would not do that but you know
the cynics aspiration is to have
complete self-sufficiency like a hero
or a god and so their uniform is
part of that that's what allows them to
live this
god-like existence as well as following
principles
relying on reason and deliberation
and here he contrasts his own
way of living with that of lucian and
other people he says that
you know you're never happy with
anything you know when it's
uh winter you want it to be summer when
it's summer you want it to be winter
you're fastidious and peevish like
invalids um you know with them it makes
sense because they're actually sick but
you've just got a sick character
you uh you you make fun of us when we
make mistakes and practice and you tell
us that we should change our plan
and correct our principles but you don't
actually have any principles you just go
and do things
kind of at random you follow your habits
you follow your appetites
you don't follow reason and deliberation
instead you're just you know changing
your plan of life
all the time and he says you're no
better than people washed
about by a flood they drift with the
current you with your appetites you let
your appetites lead you
and then he tells this story about a
person on a vicious horse
he says the horse ran away with him and
at the pace it was going he could not
get off
a man in the way asked him where he was
off to and he says wherever the horse is
going
wherever the beast chooses and he says
so if a person asked you where you were
bound for if you cared to tell the truth
you would say wherever your appetites
choose or in particular
where pleasure chose today where fancy
chose tomorrow
where avarice chose another day
sometimes rage sometimes fear
sometimes any other feeling you don't
have control over your own
life and then he says it's even worse
you don't just ride one horse you're
riding a whole bunch of horses and they
take you all over the place
they're carrying you straight for pits
and cliffs you don't realize that until
the fall comes
i'm not doing that i'm doing something
different i am living
a consistent life that to go back to the
key idea
allows me to enjoy sufficiency allows me
not to feel need my needs are fully met
i'm not destitute and it's precisely
because i'm not taking on
too much i'm not allowing myself to
desire the things that
you desire foolishly and so
the cynic is saying this is the
lifestyle
that one needs to live if you really
want to enjoy sufficiency
and freedom from want or need
you